how are you feeling now that you and
Kendall are officially together I'm very
happy about it yeah she's an amazing
person and you know it's no it's fun you
know when she came to visit you in
Chicago
you said you weren't sure if you could
get back to that place with her what was
the key to getting those emotions back
and being in a good place again I think
was just spending time with each other
and especially off-camera and learning
more about each other I mean there's
only so much you learn in Paradise and I
think you know in Paradise I think
you're worried like is it really gonna
work outside and it just I don't just
kept working so it's like why not you
know what is it that you love about her
you talked about how you guys are
opposites how she was maybe a little
afraid of commitment but what makes it
work I love when she gets mad it's funny
it makes me laugh what's that face on
and it's really funny well you talked
about how you guys were kind of
opposites and Joe said maybe that
freaked you out a little bit what is it
about him that you really do love I
don't I are very opposite I think it's
probably I love about him it's just like
we he's just like a goofy guy he's such
a goofy guy and on paradise
you know although it's a very serious
was a lot of drama happening I think Joe
and I connected because we were able to
just like laugh at all the weird crazy
things that were happening and the
almost felt like we kept each other sane
by acting insane
you